[Music]
foreign
[Music]
years of my life
living out my wildest dreams
Bianca
Rocky
my dad
this is built on their shoulders
[Music]
let me get autograph no I ain't sounding
an autograph but get off my car you
don't remember me huh
[Music]
Damien
how long were you locked up 18 Years bro
just got out last week
I know I've been away a long time but I
got myself in shape I still got gas in
the tank come by the gym
thank you
[Music]
who cares what happened with you too I
didn't tell you he was like brothers
I was the best though man I never got a
chance to prove that that's cute
oh
do nothing
Damien's fighting the world he's trying
to hurt people I bounce for you you
think you mad trying to spending half
your life in the cell
why did somebody else live your life
I'm coming for everything you
threatening me
something is going on with you
Batman was like family
[Music]
now we passed talking then maybe you
just have to find out
[Music]
family times I recognize mine I know
that they needed me
only fear I ain't scared of death did
you hear me yet
I need you to make all your fear
they're called a guilt
now go whatever was and walk into what
is I feel those chains are breaking yeah
I swear God I don't fear deaths
foreign
[Music]